then what were your favorite scenes to
shoot yeah I loved the adrenaline of
doing of being on a stationary motorbike
with rain lashing in my face in a studio
with someone dressed in like a green
alien suit kicking my bike behind me
never been happier I didn't know that
that was a thing
who is this man I'm her Godfather
get back
[Music]
what was it like when you found out that
you were joining the Indiana Jones movie
that was going to you know send off this
iconic character and actor at the same
time it's real daunting exciting I was
just so excited by the script the script
was just so brave and how it tackles
time and indie's age I just thought it
was such a cool way to complete his
story and just a real honor to be part
of such a huge franchise yeah it was
definitely thrilling like you said like
the script really honors what this
franchise has been and where it needed
to end and and to be part of that felt
really special now Phoebe every single
thing that you've written coming from a
really big feedback fan here is an
absolute Masterpiece
thank you thank you uh did you have any
input on the writing of Helena or what
were parts of her that were yours
um I can't really claim anything in
particular because she leapt off the
page to me when I read her and there's
that there's such a
in such a gift when you read a script
and the character makes sense to you and
you also feel like oh I can do this like
I know for some reason I feel connected
to this person and that is that's about
like casting something right and the
best gift you can give an actor is to
cast them with something that feels like
there's a resonance and I resonated with
her
um and so whatever came out of like me
and Helen are doing this together
um really started there I spoke to Jim a
lot along the way and uh you know I I
really wanted to keep her
you know upbeat and joyful in a kind of
she's incredibly smart but I wanted her
kind of her her her lack of awareness of
like consequences she's never really
suffered proper proper consequences and
even the one she has like if she was in
jail for a couple of years she kind of
was like hey it was jail there's
something about her that is not
completely connected to real life and
she's in denial and and I think that
that was like part of the journey that
eventually she's faced with someone she
loves and she might lose them and
suddenly everything becomes very real to
her so I really wanted to keep that kind
of like almost sort of almost sort of
delusional everything's gonna be fine
um yeah
um sort of energy that she had yeah like
just super positive yeah I love that and
I really didn't want to like call him
like I didn't want her to have to call
him like an old guy or like use any of
those kinds of insults with him and that
was a debate that um Jim and I had the
whole time so I was like I would she she
doesn't see people in that way she's got
a a sidekick who's 14 and she's going on
an adventure with someone who's in his
late 70s I just don't think she sees
people in in that way so she's just sort
of like if you're useful to me we'll go
if you're not
sorry yeah see you later
National play agent Mason in this movie
what it is about her that pulled you
into the role I think it was it was cool
to to kind of be in of uh authoritative
position to kind of um be thrusted into
a situation where you suddenly need to
to be a leader and then take the Helm of
but I also love the idea of it not being
just a perfectly
um match you know she Liz she is a bit
like off-kilter she is a little bit
trying to figure things out in the
moment and that struggle and that
tension is very fun to play you know
both of you got to rough up like
Harrison Ford a little bit in the movie
what was it like working with him in
certain action scenes because me
personally like I would be scared to put
a finger on him well you actually
probably had to I didn't I mean I
interrogated I had a verbal you know
lashing but not necessarily a more of a
physical thing um
and but he can handle it he can
definitely handle it he's
definitely in shape more in shape than
many of us are at you know half his age
but um and I'm not half his age I'm
younger than that but um
he definitely held his own um it was
actually incredible to watch him kind of
do his own stunts a little bit and some
of the fight scenes um be handcuffed and
still be able to get up you know without
putting and bracing on anyone it just
really Nimble so what were your favorite
scenes to shoot
[Music]
the action scenes anything with action
action action I just want to do action
forever
yeah I loved the adrenaline of doing of
being on a stationary motorbike with
rain lashing in my face in a studio with
someone dressed in like a green alien
suit making my bike behind me never been
happier I didn't know that that was a
thing
like this and then
oh God it was just so much fun no Helena
and indy are very different from each
other but they sort of work well
together despite you know the years of
separation how did you and Harrison Ford
um come up and build that chemistry I
think when you know the character you're
playing it affords you a kind of um a
confidence to go in with that when you
in the first place when the door first
opened and they were like you're about
to meet Harrison Ford that's like
getting the door opened you know I came
in knowing I have to I have such deep
respect with this man and but I also
have to be able to meet him on a level
for this to work because they have to be
a man for each other so I went in with
that kind of nerves and I was like how
do I
there's a risk that I could come in and
be like
familiar or something but luckily I
walked in and he just went hey hey from
the first moment I saw him and he was so
warm and so cool and so interested in my
thoughts and my take on everything and
we just got talking immediately like old
friends I felt like I'd known him for
like 2000 years it was really really
lovely and kind of meeting him so that
was lovely and you know he checks in all
the time you know he's like what do you
guys think and that makes a big
difference and whenever I'd be like
talking about let's
why don't we like rehearse this little
moment I think it'd be quite fun he's
like no we've already got it like save
it for the when the camera's on kind of
thing saying that was it's kind of
organic but also you do I think I don't
know the fact that we were playing those
characters
whatever you shown at them those are
like meeting and working person for it
for the first time oh this is really
great um and just he's just a human
which is great to kind of like dispel
any fear about someone you know of his
caliber putting on heirs or being a
little bit of a I don't know a diva in
some sense um my upbringing I was like
you know Mr Ford and me just the media
was like do not come Mr Ford it's
Harrison you know like and that felt you
know really love it like we're you know
we're simpatico it's just we're the same
and in a lot of ways we're both actors
um and that was that was really lovely
but now I know this movie deals with
time traveling a little bit
um if you guys could go back to any
point in time in history to experience
what would it be and why
[Music]
that is there was apparently a meeting
between King Herod and Cleopatra that no
one really knows what happened happened
in that meeting but she famously didn't
manage to seduce him in a way that she
managed to seduce many other um
political men and I want to be
fly on that wall
isn't that amazing I think I just I
would just want to be back in um
1920s Harlem Harlem Renaissance all of
the the art and literature and and
energy of that time period in that that
area of our of my city I'm from New York
um would have been really really lovely
[Music]
thank you